OK.
This is this is a sort of a complicated thing
to discuss.
But at some point, we, meaning the United
States collectively, we're going to owe the
world an explanation and an apology.
And I don't mean just generally for Donald
Trump, but I'm talking more broadly because
of our failure on Corona virus.
I'm talking broadly because of our failure
to continue leading on climate change.
I'm talking about our failure really to just
hold back the advancement of humanity, instead
regressing dramatically over the last three
and a half years and maybe for another four
now to set the stage accurately.
I'm not pretending that the United States
nor the world were idealist panaceas during
the era of Barack Obama.
That would be revisionist history.
That would be wrong.
That's certainly not the point of the segment
to pretend things were just perfect until
Donald Trump became president.
But as an example, we were at least an important
part of thinking about how to deal with climate
change when Barack Obama was president of
the United States.
We hadn't figured it out, certainly, but we
were serious participants in the conversation.
The Obama administration understood the U.S.
is disproportionately relative to our population,
a big polluter, a big emitter of of of pollution
and emissions.
And we were taking it seriously.
Not enough was done.
We had not figured it out, but our role was
at least respectable around the world.
Our role now on climate change has gone from
respectable to not respectable to having no
role whatsoever because we're actually a huge
part of the problem.
As Donald Trump has claimed, that climate
change is a hoax created by China, propped
up oil and gas while loosening car emission
standards.
And the world has rightly started either.
Ignoring us in these important climate change
conversations are actually pointing out that
we're a huge part of the problem on Corona.
Of course, this administration has proven
that it still matters who is president.
We have seen arguably one of the worst responses
in the world to the pandemic.
I don't know how much time I have to spend
on that today since we've covered it almost
daily for months.
But suffice it to say, almost any functioning
adult would have said, I don't need to lead
this, let's defer to the doctors and we'd
be better off.
Right.
We didn't need anything outlandish to better
handle corona virus than the way this administration
has handled it.
We just needed some adult to say, oh, I'm
not an expert in this, but I know who is.
Let's let let let let's allow them to lead
the way.
We've talked about voting Trump out as only
being the first step.
And that's true from a policy standpoint,
but it's also true from the standpoint of
defeating Trump ism.
Defeating Trump will not instantly end Trump
ism.
If Donald Trump loses in November and leaves
the Oval Office in January.
But there is another area in which defeating
Donald Trump is only the first step, which
is starting to rebuild our alliances around
the world, starting to recover some semblance
of respect from our historical allies and
from the people of this planet.
So this is not about being ashamed of the
country, even though certainly you wouldn't
be wrong to feel that right now as we have
become a laughingstock.
This is not about punishing Trump supporters,
although there's no doubt that they are responsible
for the fact that this president was elected.
This is about realizing that part of being
respected again and rebuilding those relationships
is going to be an implicit apology, some kind
of explanation as to our commitment to fixing
the disaster that the United States has been
globally during the time of Donald Trump.
Now, if Donald Trump were to win in November,
the case for such an apology and an explanation
and a rehabilitation of our reputation becomes
much more difficult.
Almost 63 million people voted for Donald
Trump in 2016.
The reality is some number close to that or
even more are going to vote for him again
in 2020.
The question, of course, is going to be do
enough additional people vote for Joe Biden
such that Donald Trump loses in the Electoral
College?
Now, in the next segment, I'm going to talk
about the reality that any view that thinks
Biden's got.
This is not based.
In fact, I'm going to go into detail about
that after the break.
But let's imagine, even if Donald Trump is
defeated in November, there will still be
the inconvenient and humiliating reality that
somewhere between probably 60 and 65 million
Americans in all likelihood, will have seen
the last four years of Trump and the disaster
that it's been.
And they will say, I'm voting for another
four and they will vote.
For Donald Trump, a second time.
So how do we get out of this?
Removing Donald Trump is only going to be
step zero point one in the process.
The world deserves answers.
The world deserves an explanation.
We owe it to the world and an explanation
about how we will not allow the country to
be hijacked by the non-thinking ideas of the
60 plus million people who, even if Trump
loses in November, will have voted for another
four years.
So what is the path forward?
I actually don't have the answers.
I want to hear from you.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
We'll take a break and we'll follow up about
this either tomorrow or next week.